now i have uh met your family before
your family has come by to visit this
show and asked me to apologize to you
and uh
but but when i when i i met them i i
said you come off and and it turns out
that they they have been fairly recently
they visited you didn't they yes well i
hosted my whole family in california for
christmas this year which was a big deal
that's a big deal yeah i know because
you have a new place don't you yes sir i
stay out here for for a great deal of
the year and uh this is the first time
that any of the kids had hosted and it
was the first time half of them had been
to california and i don't think one of
them had been west of the mississippi so
it was a
it was a fun time
and they did they take a plane here is
that what they got how they got here
yes conan
just asking questions just trying to
find out i think they cut the back off a
model t and put a rocking chair in it
yeah
[Laughter]
all right well uh i understand you spent
some time with your family
did you bring them to work at all or no
you just well no oh okay so um i was
just you know it was quite a relaxing
vacation and
and they were very uh very gracious
guests and uh you know a couple times
you'd hear little things like
oh he's gone on hollywood he's got
wireless internet and all his
all his plates match
[Laughter]
um but now one thing i did have to do
for work was and this was a couple
months ago my parents had come to visit
me
you have to do uh audio commentary for
dvds
so we went and um they 30 rock wanted me
to do one and i was like well my parents
are in town is it okay if they just tag
along then the producers of 30 rock were
like
would your parents do audio commentary
for the dvd and i was like
i guess
your parents
did the audio commentary of a 30 rock
episode they did uh
we heard about this i have not seen this
yet anything we need to know before we
we show it
one thing you do need to know is that
you know this is in the summer time and
we had a good laugh blah blah didn't
think about anything we said on it so on
christmas day you know after dinner and
stuff we all sat down to let's watch our
episode won't that be
fun and then we realized that we talked
about other members of the family
and maybe not in the most flattering way
all right
and uh it's there for all time
audio commentary let's take a look at
this uh clip audio commentary from an
episode
30 rock
i believe that when you have a problem
sometimes you're praised
alex remind you
of your men's pete when you take that my
brother
yeah i don't think so
sometimes
i think so except people
talking like they know everything
kinda sorta yeah
they both have big kids they're both
he doesn't have a big well i guess he
does a little bit i'm very very smart
and want everybody else to know it all
right i hope pizza i gotta listen
we might have to stretch this out
[Applause]
[Music]
he wasn't mad but i mean it must be
jarring just to hear you being talked
about on dvd commentary yeah as sort of
a self-centered guy who you know
well anyway that's your point not mine
um
you speaking of your family this is
sweet you brought a picture of uh you
and your siblings at christmas from
childhood yes and i just want you to
this is in georgia georgia
we never had like white christmases or
or anything but every now and then we
did get snow in the winter time so i
think this is a picture of us
celebrating you got i guess a little it
looks like you didn't get a lot of snow
here
just baby really sad
is that supposed to be a snowman
it's about 80 dirt